so you were in film school for what was
it one month
yeah I'm basically a month I was I
didn't do too well in high school
although I got an amazing SAT score I
didn't study but I just did really well
on the SATs I was always a good test
taker
but for junior and senior year I didn't
actually go to high school I think I had
like a record-breaking like 42 absences
and I just never really liked school I
didn't like the system and I didn't like
learning about things I didn't have any
interest in I always was I tested highly
gifted so they tried to put me on like
an accelerated track and I just didn't
want to do it I wanted to do my own
thing which was creative stuff and at
that time I was throwing raves and so
and and hoping do PR for music artists
and that was way more fun so I I used to
pay people to you know say they were me
in class and sign in on the sign-in
sheet so I went I I didn't do well in in
the last two years of high school so I
didn't have the grades to go to a good
film school like you know UCLA or USC
which is where I wanted to go so and my
parents couldn't really afford it either
they had just gone through a divorce and
sold the house I grew up in and stuff so
and put both of my older sisters through
college so they told me they wouldn't be
able to pay it and so I didn't want to
grow up in student loans you know like I
didn't want to grow up in debt so I went
to Community College and that was SMC
Santa Monica Community College and I was
there for a month
and while I was there I was also working
at a sandwich shop which was my second
job I ever had and actually my last
straight job I ever had and when I was
working there I making sandwiches and
then going to these film classes at
SMC and you know the first thing first
day of class we're sitting in me in the
class we watch No Country for Old Men
and the teacher goes okay and what did
you guys think of it and nobody raises
their hand so I raised my hand and I
start talking about the nihilistic
themes in the film and really getting
in-depth into it and then the teachers
like excited it's the first day and he's
like yeah this is great what are you
guys thinking everybody's like quiet and
then like one girl slowly raises her
hand and goes I liked it and everybody
was like oh yeah I liked it too oh yeah
he was a that guy in uh he was really
good the Javier Bardem or whatever and I
was I was like um I was trying to talk
about like real stuff in the movie
and so I I I just didn't like being
there so they had a thing where you know
they assigned it in the beginning of the
year that by the end of the year you had
to either write a script or make a short
film or something like that and you had
to write like a short script and so I
started writing a short script and I
really liked the short script and I
started writing it into a feature script
and then I finished the feature script
and my pure joy and I just started
hitting up friends of mine going hey I
want to make this movie all I need is
$7,000 $7,000 is all I need to make it
that's all that Robert Rodriguez had to
do el Mariachi I'll try and make it work
so I tried to get seven grand
and I ended up talking my friend and
then business partner later Jarrett
Cohen and he gave me the seven grand to
make the movie and I remember I I just
stopped going to school dropped out to
make the movie because I couldn't deal
with their schedule and I was working at
the sandwich shop and I remember they
called me and they're like hey we need
you to come into work today and I was
like I can't do that you know I'm I need
to do pre-production on this movie and
they're like well do they're like like
is it a real movie and I was like yeah
it's a real movie it's like a low-budget
indie I'm it's seven thousand dollar
budget and the guy laughs and he goes
well you got to ask yourself do you want
to make a small little
indie film or do you want to have a job
and I was like I want to make a small
little indie film piece and I hung up
the phone and never went back and I
haven't had a regular job since and kind
of like two mortal eyes that I got life
tattooed on my knuckles which some
people thought was stupid because they
thought it was like I don't like thug
life but for me it was you can't get a
restaurant job or a straight job when
you have tattoos on your knuckles and so
it was for me it was getting rid of my
fallback meaning that this is my life
this is what I'm gonna do and if I leave
a fallback for myself anytime things get
hard I'm gonna try and go to the
fallback and things get hard they really
do but as long as you don't have a
fallback you know that you got to keep
pushing forward and hustling and I think
I think you know I I talked with Wes
Craven once when we were working on
something and he he said that and I
really took it to heart that filmmaking
isn't judged by how great of a filmmaker
you are a career in filmmaking is judged
by the ability to persevere if you
believe in yourself as a filmmaker and
keep pushing forward against all odds
those are the people that change things
those are the people that actually do
and I want to be a doer and I want to
keep pushing forward and I believe that
you know it's not always an easy road I
grew up with my dad being a writer he
was you know the head writer on Pinky
and the brain and Animaniacs he won
three Emmys and a WGA award and I
remember sometimes we had a lot of money
and sometimes I didn't get presents for
the holidays and it's because there's
ups and downs and as long as you can
ride it out and choose to persevere and
go through it you'll do okay
you